(gentle orchestral music)
- It was for me, pretty
difficult to find out
how much I would emphasis on the emotion
because you can destroy with music,
very quickly, the intimacy.
We recorded with a full
on 40 string orchestra
and then I used the filter
that cut everything off.
On top of that, we
could hear every breath.
It was a little bit like the inner voice.
(gentle orchestral music)
(upbeat jazz music)
- We knew we were gonna use
the lineup of a jazz band
but we didn't want it
to feel like '20s jazz.
So we talked about the
feeling of rock and roll.
We wanted a lot of really
heavy driving riffs.
(upbeat jazz music)
And then we would give it to
unison horns or unison saxes
and it would give this
real muscularity to it.
(upbeat jazz music)
(gentle music)
- It still leaves the question,
how much does the music want
to say about what's going on?
I try not to get ahead of the
actors, of the characters,
of what they're feeling and experiencing,
but still treat it very subjectively
from their point of view.
(gentle orchestral music)
- The laundry and taxes cue,
which continues through that scene,
that was one of the most
tricky scenes to score
because it was so significant
a moment emotionally
(dramatic orchestral music)
that just called for a kind of effusive,
like a giving in to the
melancholy and the sweetness.
(playful orchestral music)
- Composing for me is
really like sculpting.
I mean, you really take
a chunk out of the stone,
another chunk, and
finally it reveals itself.
It isn't the music, it
isn't the orchestra,
it isn't the composer.
It is this interconnection
of all of these elements
that makes music, music.
(bright piano music)
(no audio)